as we continue to learn more about the
train derailment that took place in Ohio
and we continue to cover it it's harder
and harder to avoid this sub story
that's come up about some breaking
related regulations that were put in
place by the Obama Administration that
the Trump Administration rolled back now
the reason I haven't spoken about that
yet is it's genuinely unclear to me and
apparently to others as well whether
those regulations are actually related
to what took place in this particular
train derailment I have a friend who's a
train engineer and he looked at it very
strongly and he said yes that happened
but it's not clear yet at least that
that's related to this train derailment
but putting that aside for a moment that
topic has now even made it to Fox and
Friends even Fox and Friends who you
know the interesting thing about this
story
is that it has gone somewhat bipartisan
because I mean it's it's kind of crazy
but from some of the right they're
interested in the train derailment not
because they care about trains or they
care about regulation but because they
believe the media doesn't care about the
train derailment because a lot of the
victims in Ohio are white
I know it's crazy and we already talked
about that on the Wednesday show but
regardless it's leading to right-wing
media caring about the train derailment
they also see it as an opportunity to
criticize Transportation secretary Pete
Budaj Edge and Democratic President Joe
Biden so needless to say I have to tell
you I was surprised even Fox and Friends
is Brian Kilmeade yesterday morning
mentioned this issue of those regulatory
changes right uh speaking of the White
House apparently regulations regarding
train safety well this is Steve uh Steve
Ducey not kill me change during the
Trump Administration uh this particular
Railroad and others lobbied president
Trump to dismantle an obama-era rule
that would have required railroads to
update their braking systems and uh
apparently the Obama administration had
pushed for it to govern transportation
of hazardous materials after about half
a million uh barrels of crude were
dumped But ultimately the Trump
Administration undid that and said the
cost exceeded the benefits nobody
understands and you know when they talk
about whether or not it's safe to drink
the water okay so then they get off of
that aspect that is absolutely and
completely true if you Google this
you'll find it widely documented here's
one article Trump rolls this is from
2018. Trump rolls back train breaking
rule meant to keep oil tankers from
exploding near communities and the
article reads trains that carry oil and
other flammable material won't have to
install won't have to install
electronically controlled brakes that
reduce the risk of train derailment and
explosions after the reversal by Trump
officials of an Obama era safety rule
the pipeline and hazardous materials
safety administration posted the rule
change on its website and again they say
today this was from September of 2018
arguing the cost of installing these
more sophisticated breaks outweighs the
benefit this was first proposed closed
in December 2017 around the time of a
deadly Amtrak derailment and finalized
today the improved brakes had had a 2021
deadline for installation so it is 100
percent true that this was something
that was started during the Obama
Administration a deadline was placed on
it
under Trump that was canceled
I would want to be really sure
that it's actually related to this train
derailment before we ascribe this train
derailment blame under that umbrella but
it still goes without saying that we are
not over regulated when it comes to
trains by any means and in fact it's
probably the opposite but ultimately we
will have a more specific answer here
and I mean listen good for Fox News for
bringing it up they get they mention it
as an aside and they get off of it very
quickly but they did bring it up to
their credit
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself for
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below